everyone thank you for coming we're
going to be talking about dynamic object
games tracking with opencv today so
before we get into it just a little
background about our lab we're led by
John Pearson over there who you may have
attended his Julia tutorial on Wednesday
and our focus is on computational
techniques applied to complex behavioral
and brain data including a lot of
machine learning and if you're more
interested in that sort of stuff or you
like what you see today in our talk go
ahead and check out our website at
pearson lab github i oh we have some
blog posts that go into more detail
about what we did here and um links to
our github and that sort of stuff so
before I talk about specifically what we
were doing I thought I'd give a brief
background on I tracking so I tracking
started in about the 1950s with a
Russian psychologist named Alfred y
Arbus he performed these experiments
with this complicated device that like
reflected light off the retinas and then
like like using film like basically
recorded where people were looking with
respect to a piece of artwork and you
can see the experiments that he was
running right here on the right side of
the screen basically he'd show one piece
of art and then tell people to do
different things with that hard so like
remember the clothes worn by two people
or give the ages of the people and he
found that the gaze patterns for these
were drastically different depending on
the task that people were given so that
was kind of the beginning of eye
tracking and since then in modern times
I tracking is used widely for everything
from human-computer interaction to
market research to psychology and
neuroscience like we're using it today
so basically there are two mode
of this research one is static I
tracking which is what your Arbus was
doing where you're looking at an image
and you're tracking basically where
people are looking on that image and
nowadays it's done with screen-based I
trackers so you're getting coordinates
of where people are looking with respect
to a screen with an eye tracker attached
to it and the advantage of that is that
the analysis becomes a lot easier
because you know exactly where
everything is on the screen but it's
limited in that you're in a controlled
environment where you can basically only
track what people are looking at on a
screen so the other modality of eye
tracking research these days is
head-mounted eye tracking including I
trekking glasses which is what we were
working with the disadvantage to that is
that analysis becomes a lot harder
because you're only getting gaze
coordinates with respect to a video
camera on the eye tracking glasses so
our problem that we're trying to solve
here today is how do we do complex
analysis on I tracking glasses data so
this is an example of what we were
working on basically on the Left we have
a frame from our eye tracking glasses
and it's probably not very noticeable
but there's a blue circle near the head
of the man in the piece of artwork and
that's just showing where the person is
looking and we're trying to translate
that to the static image so that we have
people that are like you know like if
they're in art museum they're walking up
close to the image there zooming out
there doing all sorts of different
things coming from different
perspectives we want to map those gays
coordinates just to this static image so
that's the problem that we're trying to
solve and before I show you what we did
I just want to show you the results so
that you know what we're working towards
in this talk
so you can see like even when part of
the image is cut off or like perspective
is changing the mapping to the static
image remains consistent
alright so that's what we're going to be
trying to accomplish first I want to
talk about the hardware that we were
using so we were using the Toby pro
glasses too there's a lot of eye
tracking glasses but we found that these
would be the best for our purposes for a
few different reasons one is that they
have four infrared sensors that they use
corneal reflection to create a 3d model
of the eye and by building that 3d model
that allows them to compensate for like
glasses slipping down or like slight
perturbations so you get a more accurate
gaze position readout another nice thing
about them is that they have an
accelerometer and a gyroscope so that
they track motion during the experiments
that we run and the best thing about
them is that they implement a REST API
so you connect to them via Wi-Fi and
then all of your interaction with them
is via HTTP calls so its language
agnostic and you're not forced to use
their proprietary software for data
collection and analysis so we were able
to create our custom solution a little
bit about the software that we used we
used opencv for image analysis so we did
it frame by frame ffmpeg for encoding
decoding video once we had the frames
and docker because building opencv with
ffmpeg is surprisingly difficult so we
just wanted to do it once and then build
a docker container for it so that if
people wanted to use our code we could
just have them run a few commands and if
you go to our website there's a blog
post about getting the docker container
and running it a little bit more
background about opencv because that's
mainly what we're going to be talking
about today basically opencv is just a
collection of highly optimized computer
vision algorithms it's written in C and
C++ but there are bindings to Python and
Java as well
and it can be run on a bunch of
different platforms and it's just like a
very popular library that's well
maintained so a little bit more about
the subject of our experiment we're
having people look at artwork we decided
to do artwork because natural viewing is
really important in that scenario so
like viewing our work on a screen as you
can imagine is very different from
viewing it in a museum in like a very
natural setting so you wanted to capture
that the two pieces that we use are
called decomposition ejects on house and
family tree by one gets emu to family
tree is actually a collection of I think
12 of these types of images they're like
abstract face representations so we
actually chose both of these pieces of
art for their abstract representations
of faces now you may be wondering why do
we choose faces so this is where the
neuroscience comes into play we know
certain things about viewing faces with
in neuroscience we know that if there's
a face in an image people tend to
gravitate towards that and look at it as
you can see in that image to the words
the bottom that's just like a heat map
which is a common analysis done with eye
tracking and basically the redder or the
warmer the color the more that people
were looking at that part of the image
so they're very focused on the face here
and then we also know that within faces
people tend to look at the eyes and the
mouth and that's demonstrated on the
image to the right so the purpose of our
experiment is that we wanted to see how
much these things translated to more
abstract representations of faces in
artwork so how did we do the gays
mapping to the static image this is a
frame-by-frame process so for each frame
we attempt to find the static image
within that video frame
and then if we find the static image we
try to find the relationship between
those two spaces to account for
prospective differences and finally once
we have that relationship we apply that
to the eye tracking data so we get have
eye tracking data with respect to video
coordinates and we get out I tracking
data with respect to static image
coordinates so step one is finding a
match image in our video frame so this
seems like a very hard problem right
like you're trying to find an image
within another image but it can be from
any perspective but luckily it's very
well studied with in the commuter vision
community and there are some pretty good
solutions for it so this can be broken
down into two sub steps basically first
we want to find descriptive features of
each image that can be compared between
the two and then we want to match
features that are similar between the
two images so opencv provides a lot of
different feature detection detectors
some of these are edge detection and
corner detection but these aren't really
what we want because they're not really
robust or descriptive so we can't match
corners that are found because it's just
finding corners so we want features that
are descriptive so the answer to that
problem would be using sift features
which stands for scale invariant feature
transform and these are robust to
obviously its scale invariant so they're
robust to scale as well as perspective
and they provide a rich description of
what is contained inside the feature
that is found so each sift feature gives
you a point and like a size that it
corresponds to as well as a 128
dimensional feature vector that
basically describes what is in that
feature that it's found and you can use
that to compare across features and find
similar
cheers so these are the sift features
calculated for each image on the Left
video frame and on the right are
matching image as you can see some of
the features correspond to a larger size
and some of them of course want to a
smaller size but the feature descriptors
will remain the same no matter the size
of them so like for example on the video
on the left if someone were to walk back
ten steps those features would still
have the same feature descriptors but
the sizes of the features would change
so once we have features for both images
we can match them and we do this with an
algorithm called flam which stands for
fast linear approximate nearest
neighbors so regular nearest neighbors
the basic process for that would be for
each feature in the match image you
would want to find the closest feature
in the video frame through Euclidean
distance and Euclidean distance is
basically just like if you have like two
points let's say you have two points in
a two-dimensional surface and you draw a
line between them the distance of that
line Euclidean distance is just
generalized to n dimensions so in this
case it would be 128 dimensions of the
feature space so we're finding the
closest straight line between two
features so that's regular nearest
neighbors and we decided to use the
approximate nearest neighbors algorithm
because it's a lot faster and we found
that we found that we don't need to find
exact matches most of the time and at
the approximate nearest neighbors as you
can see here does a pretty good job of
matching the similar features so once we
have those matches we need to find the
relationship
between the frames so the video frame
and the static image so how do we define
this relationship we can define it as an
affine transformation which is just a
transformation that preserves points
straight lines and planes but it can
account for changes in perspective so no
curvature can be added but it can
account for changes in perspective so if
you look at this image to the right each
leaf in that image can be obtained by an
affine transformation on another leaf so
reflection rotation scaling shear
mapping those can all be accounted for
by an affine transformation so how do we
parameterize an affine transformation
that would that would be with something
called an affine matrix which is just a
3 by 3 matrix that you can apply to an
image and get the affine transformation
that corresponds so the FI matrix is
what we need to find the FI matrix that
corresponds to going from the video
frame to the static image so how do we
find that out fine matrix there's a
function in opencv called fine kamagra
fee and basically what this function
does is it takes a set of source points
in a set of destination points that
correspond to each other and finds in a
fighh matrix that that fits those data
so in this case we would be taking our
matching features are set of
corresponding matching features and
finding the affine transformation
between them and we have to specify a
method for this function for fine
tomography and we used something called
ransack and the reason we use that is
because its robust to outliers so let's
say if I go back here really quickly
let's say you have like so most of these
look like they're fitting pretty well
but let's say you have one that just
like like matches this corner over here
so that would be an outlier because it's
not the same affine transformation as
the
so the points what ransack does is that
it's robust to outliers so you can have
we can use our approximate nearest
neighbors algorithm because like it's
going to be accurate most of the time
and when it's not accurate when we're
finding the mammography matrix the
affine matrix this ransack method will
ignore those outliers so this image on
the right demonstrates the affine matrix
being applied to the video frame so
basically it you just send in the video
frame use fine tomography and then
another function called apply
perspective transform or something like
that and then you get the video frame in
the static image space as you can see
it's cut off at the top because in the
video the top of that piece of art was
cut off but the coordinates all line up
which is pretty cool and this can
actually be applied in the other
direction simply by inverting the matrix
so you can go from the static image
coordinates to the video frame
coordinates just by inverting the matrix
and then applying the transformation on
the static image so once we have this
affine matrix we use the perspective
transform function that I mentioned
earlier on the gays data for each video
frame because we already have a
transformation from video frame space to
static image space so that's essentially
what we did and now Jeff is going to
come up and talk about some of the
extensions that he's been working on
excellent yeah so now we have a grab the
ability to map these gays locations from
the video reference frame to a static
reference image and this allows us to
start doing some more traditional I
tracking analyses so now that we can
provide this mapping we can start with
basic questions like well what parts of
an image is the person looking at
most over time um one way to do that
it's simply just to map all of these
gays locations on to that static
reference imogen see these are these are
all the areas that the person looked at
an alternative approaches to start
making heat maps on these static
reference images in this case we're
calculating a two-dimensional kernel
density estimate over all the available
gaze points that are that are here it
would produce this this summary map in
this map is going to be indicating which
parts of the region the person spent the
most time looking at in this case on
this example from taking from the the
video which we can find that people
spend the most time looking at the head
and face regions which is what
consistent with what would be predicted
from traditional eye tracking analyses
on on static images and to produce a map
like this we took advantage of the
seaborne plotting libraries and Python
and in the spirit of this this
conference I want to give a nod to that
library they produce some really um easy
to implement and really aesthetically
gorgeous plot so I'm check that out if
if you haven't already so you can
collapse across the the entire session
as we've done here and use a library
like Seaborn or matplotlib to produce a
visualization um that summarizes the the
entire viewing behavior over the entire
session um or you can start creating
heat maps that are evolving over time so
just to play where's the mouse there it
is so in this case we have we're
calculating like those kernel density
estimates on every new time point as its
acquired as every new frame that as its
acquired um and then we can write the
new plot as a as a frame in his own
video and then use that to show the
evolution of the gays and viewing
behavior over time so before when it
should do that that static image on
those summarized over the entire session
all the attention was spend on the most
of the fixations were on the head and
face region but out if you could see in
the beginning of that video the person
starts out at least focusing on the
lower lower left quadrant of the image
and then over time kind of shifts their
attention more up to up to the face um
and as shark mentioned earlier we we
have a transformation matrix right that
will go from the video frame to the
static reference image um but we can
simply invert that matrix then you have
a new matrix that will map from the
reference image back into the video
frame so all these plots that we room we
can then take and then overlay directly
on the original source video itself
oops
what's that plane is you see that um
yeah so anyway so in this we're mapping
the gays location from the static
reference image producing that that that
kernel density map on the reference
image I'm and then projecting it back
into the video itself um did you see it
for a second at all this was fine that's
fine it's a nice did I can go back slide
yeah some this we're takin and then just
projecting it back into the original
source video itself so you can overlay
these visualizations directly onto the
directly onto the source video
yeah sorry about this we're still
mapping thing for some
give back to the
okay that's perfect okay um sorry about
that all right so great so we've been
talking about mapping from from the
reference from the video that we're
collecting onto a static reference image
um and this is really useful for for
some of the basic eye tracking analyses
we want to do and this opens up a lot of
new possibilities for allowing allowing
participants if you're dryin experiment
unconstrained free movement as they're
walking around in an environment this
freedom with it though ads in a lot of
new responsibilities that are kind of a
headache from an experimental standpoint
if if your person is moving around you'd
like to be able to track where that
person is in space and everything we've
been talking about so far is is mapping
between two dimensional two dimensional
planes that we have the two-dimensional
video and then the two-dimensional
static reference image and we started
asked about okay well would there be a
way to figure out where the person was
in the room using the information that
we that we already have access to either
sensors or things like that so our first
approach was a shark mentioned earlier
there's accelerometers and gyroscopes
that are built into these glasses and so
like art well as long as we can know the
starting location or assume a starting
location for the person these sensors
should be able to tell us something
about how they're moving over time if
anybody's ever done this in in their own
work it's a great idea in theory in
practice these sensors like all sensors
have a bit of measurement error to them
on and when you're trying to get to
position from acceleration you're
integrating twice you're integrating
first over acceleration to get to
velocity and integrating over velocity
to get to position and as such the the
influence of these tiny measurement
errors can compound exponentially over
time so if you're looking at
acceleration alone you can't really see
the the figures on the y-axis there in
that middle plot but after about a
minute and a half the person's moving at
40 meters a second on which yeah
preferences is also the same speed that
the DeLorean has to go to go back in
time um yeah and so then by the time you
get to position after a minute a half
the persons not only not in the art
museum a more but they're about a
kilometer and a half away from the
museum so there are probably ways that
we could optimize this and improve
that somewhat but we still we're talking
about errors that are two or three or
four orders of magnitude different from
what we would um what we think would be
ideal so we went back to the drawing
table and started asking like okay well
what if we'd be able to infer position
from the the camera itself from the the
frames are being recorded from the the
camera the challenge with this with this
approach is that a camera sensor much
like the retina in our eyes um collapses
the three-dimensional world onto a
two-dimensional representation a
two-dimensional plane so this means that
there are an infinite number of
three-dimensional objects in the world
that will produce the exact same
two-dimensional projection a bigger
object farther away will look the same
as a smaller object that's closer to you
the corollary to that though is that if
you know what the object in the real
world is any single unique object will
produce one and only one 2d projection
onto a camera frame and I'll tell you
where depending on where that object is
that that projection on the camera frame
will be will be unique in our case we're
working with works of art in a museum so
of course we'd know the actual size of
these of these pieces in the in the real
world in computer vision terms this is
what's called the perspective endpoint
problem and it turns out to solve it you
need to know not only the size of the
object in the real world but you also
need to know to what degree is your
camera lens distorting the images that
are that are coming in and thankfully
open stevie has tools that will help you
with both of these steps so the first
step like I mentioned is figuring out
how how was your camera distorting these
these images um and said to to start
working this calibration we can collect
a set of images of a known object in
this case we're using a chessboard
collect a lot of different images from
from different vantage points get closer
change your perspective things like that
and use and chest web pattern is really
easy and in fact opencv includes a
chessboard PNG file that you can
download print out and paste up on your
own wall as well as functions that it
will have their specially designed for
finding the corners um on the grid of
the chessboard and since you know what
the relationships between the corners
and chess board should be measuring
those relationships on your image will
tell you something about how the the
images are being being distorted um so
once you get enough examples of this ten
images or so you can get overall sense
of how
your camera is distorting your images
and you can go on the nice thing about
that is that only needs to be done once
per camera as long as you don't change
your lens those those distortion
matrices will will always be the same so
you can save it as a JSON file or
something and use it on every analysis
that you have going forward okay so now
that we've figured out the camera
calibration next school is a figure well
where was the camera on every frame of
the video that we have and we begin by
using the same steps that shark
mentioned earlier where we use this the
sift feature matching define
corresponding locations between the
video frame and though and the reference
image every feature that we've
identified on that step will be
expressed in terms of pixel pixel
locations it'll be their pixel locations
on the video frame or pixel locations on
the reference image we need to take all
of the features that were identified on
the reference image and convert those
into real-world coordinates so we define
a coordinate system for our world for
simplicity sake it works really well to
define the Z plane as though the wall
that the artwork is mounted on that that
means that any feature that that is
converted will have a Z dimension of 0
which makes things relatively easy and
then the X&Y locations we can you can
get by calculating a pixels to
centimeters or units or whatever your
real world unit is conversion factor and
then multiplying all of your pixels by
that conversion factor so for example if
we identified a feature here that was at
pixel location 340 by 250 that would
correspond to a real-world location of
about 48 centimeters 35 centimeters and
0 cement centimeters in the in disease
mention in the real world only we apply
that same conversion to all of the
features that we have so on once we have
all the features defined in 3d world
coordinates you can use opencv function
solve pnp ransack to figure out where
the camera was on that on that frame and
this will return the rotation and
translation matrices that will go from
the camera to the real world object um
and in this case the artwork is fixed in
space and so we're trying to do in the
cameras moving around it the cameras
that's on that somebody's wearing is
moving around it so we invert those
matrices to really get a sense of where
the camera is with respect to this fixed
location in space we do that on every
frame of the video
um and of course the accuracy of how
well you do this depends a lot on how
well that stiff feature matching works
inevitably there's going to be some
frames where the person's moved and
really quickly say and it was really
blurry and there wasn't a good matching
happening there um but if you look at it
it's pretty easy to actually identify
where those problematic frames were so
on the Left we have the this is a plot
of the the raw Z dimension of where the
prison where the participant was and you
can see which you see the spikes in
there the places where the people are on
the stiff matching isn't working very
well and then I'm on the left you can
just apply some basic spike filtering
I'm smoothing to get a smooth estimate
of this person's motion along this
dimension and we can do this a lot for
all the motion and orientation
parameters so at this point we know on
every time point reframe the video a lot
of information about the person what
they were doing we know where they were
looking we know where they were in space
and we know how they were oriented so
from this information we can start to
reconstruct the movement and viewing
behavior throughout the experiment it's
like here's a movie where we do just
that I like to watch we try to not break
it so in this example the UM we're
showing you a 3d reconstruction of the
proper distance of behavior throughout
the course of this we see where they
moved how they were positioned at every
time point and importantly where they
were looking at in time and we can also
start supplementing this with additional
measures that weren't weren't present
there so the circle that's showing you
their gaze location on the artwork is
sized according to the approximate
extent of visual focus based on their
distance and visual angle the phobia in
the retina so this this is a movie that
we created but the actual the model was
created using javascript is the 3gs
library for 3d modeling which is really
nice so the web the web version of this
is interactive you can pan zoom around
um and scrub back and forth in time and
really get it get a detailed look on
into what's person's doing throughout
the course of it okay so just to wrap up
some of the things that we were talking
about here I think the dynamic object
and gaze tracking that we've been
presenting is I think going to open up a
lot of new opportunities for for eye
tracking research going forward unlike
most studies this allows your
participants to have free range of
motion throughout throughout
room um and and behave in a more
naturalistic setting unlike sitting in
front of a computer screen with a you
know and in a laboratory say um and
despite this freedom the methods that
we've been discussing allow you to
really robustly quantify and
characterize on viewing behavior on
static reference images similar to what
you'd want with traditional eye tracking
as well as record movement and we've
outlined a way that you can cleanly and
reliably translate between these three
different coordinate systems we have the
video the reference image and the 3d
environment that the person send
themselves on and best of all this
mapping is done automatically there's no
need to painstakingly go in and manually
identify features on your reference
image or on the video or anything like
that it's all can happen um
programmatically so great so I just
wanted to say thanks to jonathan pearson
lab Elizabeth Johnson Duke Institute for
brain sciences and marine wardle at the
nasher museum we've all been really
helpful on this project for us and thank
you for listening